Jennifer paredes cuñada del presidente
Pedro Castillo fue escarcelada luego que
la justicia peruana anular a una orden
de prisión preventiva que estuvo
cumpliendo durante casi dos meses tras
ser investigada por colusión agravada y
lavado de activos semanas atrás una
corte o reno 30 meses de prisión
preventiva pero la segunda sala penal de
apelaciones dispuso su libertad porque
considera que ella no pretendía evadir a
la justicia al presentarse a la fiscalía
y que las comunicaciones que sostuvo con
algunos ministros de estado no deben
interpretarse como obstaculización a las
investigaciones por estas razones el
tribunal Considero que su comparecencia
con restricciones es similarmente eficaz
que la prisión preventiva pero la
fiscalía pedirá impugnación contra la
sentencia el fiscal Jorge García anunció
que el Ministerio Público presentará un
recurso impugnatorio para que una corte
superior analice con detenimiento y
mayor criterio el caso porque afirma que
la justicia ya había establecido
evidencias que determinan la existencia
de una la organización criminal que
estaría liderada por el presidente Pedro
castillo y donde según las indagaciones
de la fiscalía la cuñada del mandatario
estaría comprometida como lo vista por
su parte Jennifer paredes no emitió
ningún pronunciamiento al obtener su
libertad fue trasladada en una camioneta
al interior del Palacio de Gobierno